[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo l'émission qui revient
sur les temps forts de l'actualité
parlementaire à l'assemblée et au sénat
est avec moi pour présenter cette
émission tam tran huy
nous recevons aujourd'hui patrick kanner
bonjour et bienvenue vous êtes sénateur
et cette âme qui dresse votre portrait
bonjour patrick kanner alors vous êtes
sénateur du nord depuis trois ans et
président du groupe socialiste au sénat
vous venez d'être réélu à cette fonction
cette semaine pas de changement de
président mais un changement de nom pour
le groupe c'est désormais le groupe
socialistes écologistes et républicains
désormais plus de socialisme sans
écologie et vice versa talent et votre
crédo même si sur le terrain ça peut
être parfois plus compliqué l'union de
la gauche ça ne marche pas toujours ça
devrait d'ailleurs valu de perdre
quelques sièges dimanche dernier
patrick canard vous êtes aussi un ancien
ministre de la ville et des sports c'est
un secteur en grande difficulté
aujourd'hui dans la crise sanitaire
est ce qu'aujourd'hui il faut sauver le
sport français bien sûr avec je dirais
des mesures qu'ils ils l'ont déjà
affaiblis avant la crise sanitaire
quand on supprime des dizaines de
milliers d'emplois aidés qui était très
utile dans les clubs notamment amateurs
on fragilise le sport français
quand on transforme un ministère de
plein exercice
ansu ministère de l'éducation nationale
on fragilise le sport français
quand on n'augmente pas le budget du
sport français à quelques années de cet
événement majeur le plus grand événement
mondial à savoir les jeux olympiques
on n'est pas à la hauteur donc il faut
sauver le sport français mais il faut
signes politiques publiques qui qui le
permet avec la crise a encore empiré
oui la crise sanitaire naturellement à
diminuer des crédits à a fait peur aux
parents donc il ya moins de licenciés
dans les clubs donc il faudrait un plan
d'urgence d'un plan marshall pour et
quand vous regardez le le budget qui
consacre est donc un peu plus de 100
millions d'euros sur cent milliards dans
le plan de relance
je pense que la ministre des sports n'a
peut-être pas été assez pugnacais
pourtant sur une sportive pour défendre
cela c'est dommage vous rappelle quand
même que ça contient 17 millions de
français qui sont licenciés dans les
clubs
dix-sept autres millions qui ne sont pas
licenciés mais qui pratiquent
régulièrement aujourd'hui les salles de
sport sont fermés vous trouvez que c'est
normal
alors là c'est lié directement à la
situation sanitaire
j'ai vu je vois bien qu'il ya beaucoup
de réactions aujourd'hui font qu'on
essaye de remettre en cause cette
décision
moi je fais confiance au gouvernement je
fais confiance aux pouvoirs publics
qu'ils soient préfet ou maire pour dire
là c'est être dangereux il y à un
cluster mais dans ces cas là il faut des
mesures de compensation en tout cas le
sport a été la seule activité physique
vraiment pratiqué pendant confinement
abreu voyez-vous exactement et donc ça
veut dire qu'il ya un besoin dans notre
pays il faut savoir le respecter a les
outils très titre de cette émission le
renouvellement du sénat rime avec
stabilité la droite conforte sa majorité
les écologistes on retrouverait un
groupe gérard larcher est réélu dans un
fauteuil un projet de loi de finances
marqué par l'aco vide présenté cette
semaine en conseil des ministres il
inclut les 100 milliards du plan de
relance et enfin le plus de la semaine
est consacrée au séparatisme avec le
discours du président de la république
ce vendredi le projet de loi est attendu
pour le 9 décembre
et pour commencer cette émission gérard
larcher réélu président du sénat
[Musique]
et de quatre ce n'était une surprise
pour personne le président du sénat a
été réélu très largement pour un
quatrième mandat
les élections sénatoriales ont permis à
la droite et au centre de sortir
renforcé dans l'ensemble le scrutin a
été synonyme de stabilité une nouveauté
seulement le retour d'un groupe
écologiste au sénat 101 cerqueira ayant
obtenu la majorité absolue des suffrages
au premier tour de scrutin je le
proclame président du sénat gérard
larcher réélu haut la main dès le
premier tour pour un quatrième mandat à
la présidence du sénat dont il continue
à défendre le rôle de contre-pouvoir
que serait notre démocratie sur le
bicamérisme sans une deuxième chance qui
ne procède pas de l'élection
présidentielle chez les républicains
c'est sans suspense que bruno retailleau
a été reconduit à la tête d'un groupe
élargi de près de 150 sénateurs
l'élu de vendée se voit conforté dans sa
position au sein du groupe mais aussi du
parti de droite il n'y a pas eu une
seule voix contre lui il faut faire en
sorte que toutes ses sensibilités
puissent cohabiter à la fois avec la
liberté de chacun mais aussi dans la
cohésion dans l'unité parce que c'est le
groupe central du sénat et il faut qu'on
puisse avoir texte par textes des
majorités pas de changement non plus du
côté des centristes hervé marseille a
été reconduit à la tête de son groupe
à gauche c'est la continuité aussi avec
la réélection à l'unanimité de patrick
kanner dans l'objectif était de rester
le deuxième groupe au sénat le premier
groupe de gauche d'opposition donc au
parlement assemblée nationale comprise
le groupe lrm rebaptisé rg pays
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendant garde
également le même président françois
patriat qui obtient sept voix sur les 25
que compte le groupe face à julien
bargeton sénateur de paris
on nous avait prédit la perte de la
moitié du groupe
mon échec personnel
le fait que nous n'étions pas un groupe
qui pouvait aujourd'hui se maintenir
qu'il y avait des dissensions que non
seulement il n'y a pas de dissensions
mais en plus c'est vrai que nous sommes
un groupe qui est maintenant monte à 25
du côté des verts l'issue s'est révélée
plus incertaines le groupe renommé
groupes écologistes solidarité et
territoires a choisi guillaume gontard
sénateur de l'isère comme président
esther benbassa obtient la
vice-présidence essor très amer de son
échec
elle dénonce un coup porté à europe
écologie les verts guillaume gontard qui
n'est pas encarté aura la lourde tâche
de conduire ce nouveau groupe déjà
divisé c'est aussi un petit peu la
diversité de ce groupe parce que il y a
bien sûr beaucoup de deux sénateurs et
sénatrices qui sont élevés mais il ya
aussi des centristes qui sont à
génération il y en a d'autres qui ne
sont pas directement à relever mais des
mets des proches
enfin eliane assassi sénatrice de
seine-saint-denis a été réélu à
l'unanimité à la tête du groupe
communiste quasiment stable après les
élections sénatoriales
patrick kanner tout change mais rien ne
change les changements dans la
continuité pourquoi tant de stabilité au
sénat même équilibre même président de
groupe dont vous oui ainsi une stabilité
qui d'ailleurs peut interroger puisque
vous avez rappelé l'élection brillante
et sans suspense disons le de gérard
larcher
je rappellerai à nos téléspectateurs que
finalement depuis 1958 le sénat n'aura
connu qu'une seule alternance de 3 ans
et 3 ans mais c'est quand même
dérogation
c'est comme une interrogation alors
qu'il ya eu des alternances beaucoup
plus fréquentes entre la droite et la
gauche au niveau national dont interrogé
sur le scrutin sénatorial
voilà je pense que là la chambre du
seigle de la châtaigne représentent des
territoires mais aujourd'hui l'évolution
urbaine mériterait peut-être qu'on
s'intéresse à voilà vous avez été
finalement le fait que les territoires
sont sont à droite en france je jacte
que les territoires ruraux sont plus à
droite que les territoires urbains on
l'a encore vu d'ailleurs aux dernières
élections municipales
encore une fois qu'il ait pas de
malentendu je ne remets pas en cause
nice ni le bicamérisme la place
particulière en tant en terme de contre
pouvoirs notamment aujourd'hui du sénat
mais voilà c'est une interrogation bien
légitime quand on est le patron du
principal groupe central de gauche au
sein
du sénat en dehors de cela c'est vrai
que la principale nouveauté c'est la
création d'un groupe vert aujourd'hui e
st au sein du sénat c'est une publicité
oui bien sûr mais dans une chambre je
m'en réjouis mais en plus je nous ai y
avons largement contribué par ses c'est
bien aussi de stabilité à l'instant tam
le disait cette stabilité vous souhaitez
qu'elle s'exerce aussi dans le contre
pouvoir que joue aujourd'hui le sénat
vis-à-vis de l'exécutif le
contre-pouvoir je vous assure que nous
on va l'assurer puisque nous avons
presque une centaine de sénateurs de
gauche verts ps communistes et est
associé en temps entre guillemets donc
ça nous allons assurer j'entends
monsieur retailleau mais je vois quand
même que dans ses rangs il ya quand même
des gens qui se disent mais finalement
est-ce que monsieur macron ne serait-il
pas l air compatible pas pour l'instant
dans soit pas sa tête
on en est encore loin mais on voit des
mouvements et moi ma vraie question
c'est ce que monsieur maquereau en 2022
ge qui sera à nouveau candidat sera-t-il
oui ou non le candidat peut-être aussi
de la droite
larcher en tout il ya aujourd'hui
presque à deux ans de l'élection
présidentielle le sénat ce qui ne risque
pas justement de devenir le laboratoire
de la droite avant cette échéance et
vous quel va être votre place dans ce
contexte là le la porter de la droite
encore faut-il qu'il y une originalité
aujourd'hui
monsieur macron siphonne idéologiquement
et notamment sur le plan économique et
social la droite et j'ai d'ailleurs les
électeurs de droite et aussi les
parlementaires de droite dit bah oui sur
le plan économique et social
c'est quand même un peu notre notre
politique donc pas dire plus
donc la différence maintenant c'est la
sécurité et on voit bien et on en
parlait tout à l'heure sûrement que le
président macron va sur les terres de
droite voire même de parfois de
l'extrême droite avec les déclarations
de son ministre de l'intérieur donc à
suivre
je ne sais pas si différent elle aime
écouter le mandat qui nous attend les
les 300 demandes à sénatoriaux
sénatoriales pardon va nous permettons
nous permettre de regarder si oui ou non
les différences s'atténue ou si elle
s'accentue
je ne doute pas de l'engagement
personnel gérard marché mais gérard
marché c'est aujourd'hui un des leader
d'une droite qui se cherche énormément
alors que à gauche les choses maintenant
enfin clary alors justement alors dans
l'opposition vous nous dites la création
d'un groupe écologiste et puis vous même
votre groupe a changé de nom il
s'appelle des gens mais socialistes
écologistes et républicains
il faut y voir un message politique en
vue de 2022 il faut y voir une évolution
moi j'ai souhaité et j'ai obtenu
l'unanimité après quelques abstentions
de de mon groupe
hier après deux jours le débat pour que
le mot écologistes soient intégrés dans
notre sigle groupe socialiste et
d'ailleurs j'ai d'ailleurs sénatrices et
sénateurs voulait torpiller ce groupe
écologiste qui ont justement j'en ai
prévenu guillaume gontard il est très
heureux c'est le c'est une évolution qui
ne fait que constater notre propre
engagement savez c'est le début d'une
alliance finalement à gauche qui ce
gibier fait aussi bien mais je savais
que j'aurais la question mais est ce que
vraiment vous êtes des écologistes la
réponse est oui
quand nous portons une proposition de
loi sur les crimes déco side
quand nous portons une profonde loi
organique sur l'intégration des biens
communs dans la constitution
le travail sur les sols pollués sur les
pesticides et je vous en passe et les
meilleurs gens les deux pages
je revendique aujourd'hui le fait que
quand on est socialiste
en deux ans au 21e siècle on ne peut pas
ne pas être écologique au niveau
politique on a vu et bien pendant les
élections des listes écologistes
socialistes s'affronter est-ce que ça
c'est quand même pas un problème est ce
que vous retenez la leçon pour la sur la
concurrence permet à l'un des deux de
remporter le siège de dire je n'ai pas
de problème quand la concurrence avec
notamment des des absences de
désistement républicain fait que la
gauche perd un siège au profit de la
droite
la réponse est tout à fait négative
rakia faute écoutez moi je regarde
devant moi je ne fais pas de la
politique en regardant mon rétroviseur
je le regrette
on a perdu cinq sièges détenus par des
socialistes parce qu'il ya eu une
division de là
de la gauche je le regrette mais que
cela nous serve de leçon pascal inverse
nous avons d'agde des sièges à gauche y
compris pour les verts par l'union donc
la division c'est perdant-perdant
l'union ces gagnants ils sont retenus
pour les régionales où vous souhaitez
vous présenter dans les hauts de france
face à xavier bertrand l'année prochaine
je souhaite être une liste d'union
évident enfin si aujourd'hui à travers
ces élections sénatoriales mais aussi
aux autres élections législatives qui
ont eu lieu il y a maintenant quelques
jours
si nous ne sommes pas capables de bâtir
une union à partir d'un projet c'est pas
l'union pour l'union
c'est à partir d'un projet politique eh
bien nous serons balayés et moi je ne
souhaite pas je n'ai pas un tempérament
de minoritaires permanent on continue
avec la deuxième partie de cette
émission la présentation du budget 2021
un budget associé au plan de relance
[Musique]
budget inédit adopté cette semaine en
conseil des ministres il inclut les 100
milliards du plan de relance une somme
qui va permettre de baisser les impôts
des entreprises sont augmentés ceux des
ménages est d'encourager l'embauchent
des jeunes l amont à gaza dans cette
situation morose crise sanitaire plus
crise économique plus crise sociale le
gouvernement veut malgré tout fixer un
cap pour 2021
nous maintenons une évaluation de
croissance à + 8 % car nous sommes
convaincus que la france peut se
redresser et se redresser rapidement et
que les mesures du plan de relance
aideront à retrouver d'ici 2022
le même niveau de développement
économique que celui que nous avions
avant lac
mais avant 2022 il ya 2021 et un budget
qui affole tous les compteurs 120
milliards d'euros lui de 6 milliards
d'euros 10 milliards d'euros 45
milliards d'euros
le gouvernement mise donc sur le plan de
relance 100 milliards d'euros sur deux
ans 10 milliards déjà dépensés cette
année 30 milliards décaissés pour
l'année prochaine dans le budget 2021
plus de 6 milliards d'euros pour
financer le dispositif d'activité
partielle aider les entreprises et tenir
la promesse de ne pas augmenter les
impôts dix milliards d'euros de baisse
des impôts de production pour les
entreprises
côté particuliers suppression complète
de la taxe d'habitation pour 2023
le budget va aussi mettre l'accent sur
l'environnement un tiers du plan de
relance se sera fléché vers l'écologie
en relance parmi les ministères gagnant
de ce projet de loi de finances le
régalien avec la justice et l'intérieur
patrick kanner est ce que vous trouvez
que ce budget est sincère compte tenu de
la situation sanitaire qui est encore en
train d'évoluer aujourd'hui je ne sais
pas s'il est sincère en tout cas elle
est chère il repose essentiellement sur
du ruissellement de la dette publique
heureusement heureusement pour notre
pays c'est vous qui vous en plénière je
ne m'en plains pas je constate
simplement que aujourd'hui emprunter à
des taux extrêmement bas pour ne pas
dire négative
c'est une chance pour notre pays et il
fallait débloquer de l'argent face à la
crise l'idée qu'il fallait en charge ont
voté
nous avons voté en conscience le premier
plan de rectification d'ondés des
finances publiques dans notre pays donc
je n'ai aucun regret sur le sujet moi
simplement ce que je constate c'est
qu'en encore aujourd'hui le trait
marquant de ce budget c'est cet idiot
logique que je considère comme néfaste
de la baisse systématique des impôts
n'importe comment
j'ai envie de dire et impôts des
entreprises que coûte et les ménages
ménages
aussi je vais revenir sur l'impôt sur
les productions surproduction 10
milliards d'euros qu'on va enlever aux
régions mais qu'on va devoir donc
compenser aux régions par la dette
nationale
moi je suis très content que les
entreprises bénéficient de deux baisses
d'impôts mais en 2019 c'était 20
milliards de cice plus 20 milliards de
cotisations sociales en moins et cela
c'est du permanent puisqu'on va faire
peser sur la sécurité sociale donc sur
vous sur moi sur tout les français une
décision en faveur du mollet contre sens
et il faut des contreparties il faut
dire oui à la baisse d'impôts des
entreprises mais avec entrain et ciblée
et ciblées notamment sur les tpe et les
pme
et puis un autre sujet la taxe
d'habitation 17 milliards de recettes
vont disparaître pour les communes
compensés par l'état
mais à l'euro près sans véritablement
dynamique en la matière moi ce que je
regrette tout simplement c'est qu'encore
une fois les plus aisés de nos
concitoyens et jeu j'en fais partie je
le dis vont bénéficier d'une baisse
d'impôts sensible sur les 17 milliards
c'est 20 % de concitoyens les plus aisés
aurait été impressionné moitié pour les
20% de ménages les plus aisés
mesdames si ma réponse effectivement
c'était un constitutionnel mais c'est
donc le système de badges qui était qui
était mauvais et c'est même la
contribution c'est le consentement à
l'impôt qui est remise en cause
systématiquement jamais après la
suppression de l' isf après la création
de la flat tax pour les revenus du
capital
jamais un gouvernement même pas nicolas
sarkozy n'avait osé aller aussi loin
donc cet engouement de droite libérale
et aujourd'hui quand vous avez moins
d'impôts un jour ou l'autre vous le
paierez comment vous le paierez en moins
service public et donc ce sont les plus
défavorisés qui payeront cette vision
libérale qui est propre à emmanuel
macron à savoir que la main invisible du
marché va tout régler et que le
ruissellement que les premiers de cordée
vont tout régler malheureusement on voit
que l'idée qu'il ya une crise tout cela
tu as à la les accords avec ce budget
oui il y aura il y aura des
contre-propositions contre nos amis de
l'assemblée nationale il y aura dans ce
contrat budget par exemple nous pensons
que sur les assurances vie de plus de
cent cinquante mille euros
et bien cela mériterait peut-être une
contribution à l'effort de guerre
nationale puisqu'on parle de guerre face
à crise sanitaire
eh bien ça ramènerait près de 4
milliards plus de 4 milliards d'euros
dans le budget de l'état leur dire oui
mais 4 milliards par rapport à tous
condamnent dont on a besoin mais c'est
pas le problème
la question c'est de faire contribuer
ceux qui ont le plus bénéficié des
mesures de lehman macron depuis le début
du quinquennat à l'effort national
ce n'est pas possible de répartir
également de manière égalitaire l'effort
il faut le répéter de manière équitable
et l'équité c'est demander un peu plus à
ceux qui ont tellement obtenu est ce que
vous voterez le plan de relance palance
peut-être pas l'ensemble du budget mais
au moins le plan de relance à
l'assemblée par exemple plans de relance
publics ont décidé de le voter
la mission relance au sein du budget
comme vous avez pu choisir de voter pour
un nombre de sujets qu'il n'y a pas de
message en direction de l'effort qui
doit être demandé aux plus aisés de nos
concitoyens eh bien il ya peu de chances
que le groupe socialiste écologistes et
républicains
le vote et non pour les deux allez on
termine avec le discours sur le
séparatisme d' emmanuel macron c'était
aux mureaux en banlieue parisienne
[Musique]
le président de la république a donc
prononcé à vendredi ce discours très
attendu sur le séparatisme évoquant les
grands axes de ce projet de loi qui sera
présenté en conseil des ministres le 9
décembre prochain
il a également visé très clairement
l'ennemi le séparatisme islamistes ont
l'écoutons ce à quoi nous devons nous
attaquer c'est le séparatisme islamistes
c'est un projet conscient théorisé
politico religieux qui se concrétise par
des écarts répétés avec les valeurs de
la république qui se traduit souvent par
la constitution d'une contre société et
dont les manifestations sont la
déscolarisation des enfants le
développement de pratiques sportifs
culturels communautariser qui sont le
prétexte pour l'enseignement de principe
qui ne sont pas conformes aux lois de la
république
c'est d'endoctrinement et par celui ci
la négation de nos principes l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes la
dignité humaine le problème c'est cette
idéologie qui affirme que ces lois
propres sont supérieures à celles de la
république
patrick kanner le président de la
république a parlé de façon très claire
du séparatisme islamistes de l'islamisme
radical
il change de pied là jusque là ce
n'avait jamais été aussi clair il
n'avait pas à coller ces noms de façon
aussi claire il faut 2 mai les choses et
qui donc ça ajoute au malheur du monde
disait camus camus une phrase qu'on
répète souvent cette période c'est moi
j'ai été un ministre qui de la ville qui
en 2016 sur une émission de radio avait
dit mais je puis dire devant les
français qu'il ya aujourd'hui plus de
100 quartier qui présente des
similitudes potentiel avec molenbeek oui
mais vous partager le diagnostic c'est
aussi votre échec alors patrick kanner
c'est l'échec de très nombreux
gouvernements en tout cas les
insuffisances du gouvernement et moi
j'ai beaucoup apprécié cette tribune du
recteur de la grande mosquée de paris
tout est dit
pour combattre vraiment le séparatisme
islamistes il faut cesser de tolérer la
ghettoïsation et bien moi j'ai envie de
dire que le premier séparatisme qui
existe en france et le séparatisme
social et que depuis trois ans j'ai
écouté attentivement le discours de
d'emmanuel mâcon depuis trois ans on
retrouve le même la même idée mais sans
actions je me rappelle du discours de
bagnes le maquereau en novembre 2010 est
à tourcoing je pense qu'on peut
retrouver quasiment les mêmes mots que
s'est il passé depuis
alors là il ya des aliments il ya
notamment l'instruction obligatoire et
les halons ça c'est une flou mais
permettez-moi de fiona ventre c'est pas
la commerciale permettez moi de faire un
peu l'inventaire et l'inventaire et les
proches de zéro la politique de la ville
n'a pas été incarné politiquement il
faut le dire il n'y a pas eu de crédits
supplémentaires
et quand j'ai fait voter avec sous le
soulever des mânes de manuel valls un
plan de lutte contre la radicalisation
je vous assure qu'on avait beaucoup plus
loin de ce qui était annoncé mais il n'y
a pas eu de continuité malheureusement
c'est un plan en 2017 et vous savez ce
qui s'est passé en 2010 est donc je le
dis très simplement le présent d'un
public annoncé les choses ce matin jésus
prêt à y revenir naturellement avec vous
mais nous avons perdu trois ans dans ce
dossier parce que le séparatisme social
n'a pas été prise en considération comme
étant une priorité politique dit l'aïe
année s'annonce par exemple les annonces
l'obligation de neutralité qui sera
étendu aux salariés des entreprises
publiques parle là des dérives dans les
transports qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on
vous salariés si j'ai bien compris même
des entreprises privées qui sont dans
une délégation de service public très
c'est un grand changement c'est un
talent et vous savez le ce gouvernement
a la faculté de faire des textes qui
parfois sont pas tout à fait car et sur
le plan juridique
donc c'est sympa constitutionnel est
juge tout cas c'est une annonce
on va voir le texte figé en conseil des
ministres et après on va y travailler
très honnêtement je mets des réserves
sur la faisabilité juridique d'une telle
proposition
et rappelez vous un texte récent sur les
sorties de prison qui était durement
censuré par le constater que celle
arrivera le 9 décembre
je conseil des ministres et il prévoit
d'en parler à l'instant l'instruction
obligatoire à l'école
et trois ans à ses façons de lutter
contre ce séparatisme social chez moi
mais l'école toutefois fait dire et
faire l'école est obligatoire à 3 ans
c'est quoi l'instruction obligatoire jeu
nettement donc la maladie voilà
l'obligation ça c'est une décision
importante qui consacre potentiellement
l'école de la république et l'école sous
contrat naturellement
et quand on veut mettre aujourd'hui sur
la table fait qu'il y a de plus en plus
d'enfants qui échappent finalement et
bien au créneau qui permettent la
véritable intégration et qui permettent
de construire le pacte républicain
je crois que c'est une mesure
intéressante permettez moi quand même
d'en attendre le détail et enfin
problèmes sur les écoles
confessionnelles
or contraste est un sujet dont le sénat
d'ailleurs s'était saisie oui alors le
sénat au 13 rue agathe elle que je salue
mais quelques années auparavant la loi
kenner sur égalité citoyenneté j'avais
proposé des choses bien plus large que
cela à savoir une autorisation préalable
avant toute ouverture d'école je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il faut regarder les
choses en face
le manque d'éducation contribuer au
séparatisme islamistes donc dans ma
bouche il n'y a ni amalgame ni angélisme
ni amalgame ni angélil a dit maniaque et
où est d'ailleurs j'aurais dû faire du
copyright sur eux sur le sujet puisque
ça fait bien longtemps que que je le dis
qu'il y ait une prise de conscience des
manuels macron trois ans après son
premier discours de novembre 2010 est à
tourcoing peut-être une bonne chose mais
nous sommes à quasiment un an de la fin
du quinquennat
et cela ça cela peut interpeller les
français un mot pour conclure aussi sur
est bien le fait qu'il veuille faciliter
la dissolution d'associations les
associations c'est un secteur que vous
connaissez entendu qu ancien ministre de
la ville et des sports est ce que pour
vous il ya vraiment un terreau des
associations qui sont gangrénés
aujourd'hui par l'islamisme radical
le secteur associatif
et très facilement gangrénait pour
reprendre votre expression sanitaires on
peut créer facilement une association
naturellement les montagnes les
dissolutions facilité en tout cas avec
de nouveaux critères doit être une piste
de travail encore faut-il encore faut-il
que quand on a des dispositifs
j'en ai créé un sur le monde associe le
monde à ce défi sportif quand j'étais
ministre en fonction à savoir n'a jamais
prévu 50 inspecteur jeunesse et sport
qui était dédié aux contrôles sur le
terrain partout en france un dispositif
qui a été supprimée par l'actuel
gouvernement qu'on revienne sur des
mesures antérieures qui pouvait bien
marché
ce n'est pas moi qui dirait le contraire
simplement et on revient à votre
question initiale ministère des sports
n'a pas les moyens aujourd'hui de
langage et n'a pas les moyens merci
beaucoup patrick kanner merci brigitte
c'était donc le mot de la fin on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de parler moins d'eau
[Musique]